good morning this week I am joined by
none other than Cory Allen
he is an author meditation teacher and
host of the astral hustle podcast he's
also the creator of my favorite guided
meditation course release into now and
has completed literally thousands and
thousands of hours of mindfulness
practice during his life my intention
was to get someone who is of the highest
caliber as a meditation expert that I
could find and get them to explain the
absolute basics on the podcast the
thinking behind that was kind of like if
you wanted to learn how to throw a jab
and he got taught by Floyd Mayweather
you might actually think well his body
of knowledge is significantly wider than
this but if he can distill down all of
that knowledge into the fundamentals I
am going to get the best start within
this discipline that I can hopefully
going to break down some of the barriers
and preconceptions that you may have
about meditation if you've never done it
before and if you have done it before
Cory is going to be able to explain how
a deepen your practice and focusing on
the fundamentals irrelevant of how many
hours you've put in is never a bad thing
to do so here we go Gloria
[Music]
Cory Allen welcome to modern wisdom
thank you thanks for having me man very
good to hear from you it's really
strange to hear your voice for once
without there being binaural beats in
the background well I could put some on
if you'd like well be funny yeah the the
meditation course release into now that
you did through Oprah Marcus has been I
think I can pretty much recite it now
verbatim I could I could probably do it
back and give my best glory Allen
impression and actually actually give it
back to you that's fun is that I would
probably barely recognize that I have a
vague memories of what's in it at this
point but you know how that goes you
here for sure for sure so a lot of
listeners have heard me dance around the
topic of mindfulness practice and and
meditation over the last few months and
I think what I really wanted to do was
get someone like yourself who has a
wealth of experience with practice and
understands it from the ground floor up
and really just start to unpackage it I
think meditation for a lot of people is
like kinda like maybe a stretching
routine it's something that they know
that they probably should be doing but
that it sounds like there's maybe quite
a lot of barriers to entry it may be a
little bit complicated they're not sure
if they can complete the practice on
their own and for a common person who
hasn't ever been exposed to mindfulness
or meditation before I do think that it
can be um it can be a daunting prospect
to go into something which is she's from
the outside looking in very complex I
don't know whether in your circles now
whether you know whether you regularly
interact with anyone who doesn't do
mindfulness practice anymore but
certainly on my side there is there's a
lot of people who I think would really
benefit from it so hopefully today we
can um we can explain and we can unpack
just what mindfulness practice is and
and how everybody can benefit from it
sure yeah and firstly I mean most people
I know I would say do not have a
meditation practice is that true well
yeah yeah just because um you know I
don't know maybe 10 to 15% max of the
people I know do okay and let me just
identify the problem from the outset you
know there's a lot of confusion and
people have resistance towards getting
into meditation because as you said it
might seem intimidating or confusing or
something unreachable or unattainable
the reason for that in my opinion is and
I wrote about this a bit in my book was
that meditation is an experience it's an
experiential thing it's a you know
internal thing of the mind right it's
not something you can describe and so
the example I use in my book is that if
you were to from a from like as if you
were looking out of a camera described
the narrative of someone standing up in
the room going into the kitchen getting
a cup of coffee one could write that
description and then another person
could read that description and get the
general notion that there's a person in
a room and they're getting up and
they're going into their kitchen
whatever that may look like and they're
getting a coffee now that's an easy
picture to paint to one's mind and your
brain will fill in all the gaps and
pieces of the story that you need is
connective tissue to create that
narrative in your imagination but the
problem with meditation is is that so
now
take this same situation and now write
out what the experience of a person
standing up in their room and going into
their kitchen and making a cup of coffee
is so clearly that you as the reader can
know the first-person point of view
feeling with all the sensory and putting
all the contents that enter the
consciousness of someone who's doing
that to express that experience to
another person is so impossible
that it is really the ultimate can it be
done you should be an infinite amount of
information right it would be an
overwhelming read yeah exactly so take a
take a hundred years of people who
aren't great writers even all trying to
get at in writing about the thing the
experience yeah including all of the fat
and all the metaphysical nonsense and
you know you know all the stuff that
they can go along with that everyone's
trying to describe an intangible
experience and so there are just
mountains and mountains of descriptions
about in this intangible experience yeah
which have no meaning inherently because
they are relative only to the person
that wrote them because they're writing
about their experience so whenever an
individual who is perhaps only hearing
about the idea or an or only become
interested in meditation goes to read a
book about it or goes to look for some
type of instruction and they find 500
words on some you know bozo trying to
describe an experience it is inherently
very confusing and it's off-putting
you know it would be off-putting to me
as well so I think that the idea near
the best that's that's it the problem I
think the solution you know to break
that barrier of entry is to not write or
necessarily talk as much about the
experience but to talk about methods
that can lead people to have that
experience themselves the path not the
destination right sure yeah yeah I think
I think it's very prohibitive because as
you say everyone's experience especially
of mindfulness which is inherently so
unique and individual to the person
their brain the particular brain set up
where they go to when the thoughts begin
to quieten there's more I think I'm
right in saying there's more connections
in one square centimeter of human brain
matter than there are stars in the
galaxy and when you're trying to
describe an experience manifesting from
something as complex as that
it's um yeah you're right it leads to a
lot of information a lot of
disinformation as well and neither of
that's really helpful in getting people
to buy into the process so to speak yeah
and you hit it right there I mean what
is helpful that's what I always look at
man is like whether I am talking about
something more ordinary or I'm talking
about something more experimental or
theoretical like I I don't really talk
about unless it's useful because why
just add fat to the conversation yeah in
general it's in life really but
especially within things that are that
are intangible and transient yeah I
couldn't agree more would you say that
there's a shift at the moment towards
meditation and mindfulness becoming a
little bit more sort of newsworthy a
little bit more prevalent in day to day
discourse it's being being covered more
commercially I suppose it certainly
seems like it I mean particularly over
the last five years I think there's been
a real awareness and over the last I
think two or three years I started
seeing meditation and mindfulness on the
cover of magazines at the checkout at
the grocery store you know and now I
think there have been people who have a
lot of visibility who are promoting in
what-have-you and I do think it's
becoming a much more mainstream type of
idea in practice because it works yeah
and I think people are figuring it out
and also I think there is a you know an
enough of the badly translated Eastern
wisdom from the 60s and 70s in America
anyway it's kind of it's had time to
kind of fall away and age and die
whether it be a generational thing or
just that people finally shook it off
and there's a real nice reasonable
secular approach to mindfulness and
meditation because it doesn't need any
religious context you don't need the
theology or the ideology behind it right
yeah and also I mean that also
presupposes that there was any to begin
with yeah and a lot of these schools
some schools of Eastern thought contain
meditation as a practice in those
philosophies contain spirituality but if
you look at some you know aspect there
there are certainly unquestionably a lot
of other schools which have zero
you know quote unquote spiritual aspect
to them at all and I think one doesn't
you know need or really shouldn't seek I
think what a person would think of when
they hear the word spirituality through
meditation because really you're just
seeking your own mind yeah and unless
you are looking to your own mind as your
spiritual master which I mean I actually
have no problem with that but clear
about what's happening so anyway the
point is is that having a secular you
approach to and path to mindfulness and
meditation I think is has been it's been
laid out more and more clearly and
that's what people are responding to it
I think it makes it a lot more inclusive
by doing it in that way it permits a
much wider you so we're in an
increasingly secular society we need to
if mindfulness practice is going to be
widely adopted there there needs to be
some principles which everyone can
follow and it can't be these are
principles if you're from the West these
are principles if you from a particular
religious background or a particular
strata of society that that's not very
helpful is it and I think you're right
exporting for a secular society is a
much more inclusive way of getting your
angels started in interestingly I'm not
so sure that we're in an increasingly
secular society I think that you know
the practice of mindfulness and
meditation has become more secular
within its own yeah within itself do you
find or do you think that from what you
observed that societies in general are
becoming more secular I definitely say
so in the UK I think I think so I can't
speak for anywhere else that's the bulk
of my experience yeah I think a lot of
people are becoming very disenchanted
with what would have been the old guard
mainstay of
what communities are built around a lot
of there was a really interesting point
that came up on a Joe Rogan podcast not
long ago way said that he thinks one of
the reasons that team sports and
community sports like CrossFit are
getting such prevalence at the moment is
that previously the community that
people would have had on a Sunday when
they go to church and that sense of
belonging to a group that group identity
is falling away more increasingly now
again I can't speak for the UK effort
the USA or anywhere else but in the UK
us I certainly think people are being
more forward-thinking and less less
spiritually minded in the traditional
sense of the word mmm but yeah I'm would
you would you say that it's different in
your experience well it's just hard to
tell you know I can sample sizes right
it's like I can observe my subjective
take on it from the input and the things
I receive of course you know like I
wouldn't have thought that Trump would
be the present guy so you know I mean I
but that really collapsed my paradigm of
speculative I trust for myself so it is
haha Laurie Allen can never trust me
Corey Allen everything that's for sure
so you know I don't I don't really know
I I feel like at the very least
conversations about you know the human
condition without any spirituality or
you know monotheistic spirituality
anyway have become more public that
seems to be the case and I don't you
know this is we could get into a whole
different conversation about you know
Middle East and Islam and things like
that I don't you know it's because the
the change I think that a lot of this
tension that is being caused with world
you know the religions of the world and
in society right now is because largely
to do the internet because the Internet
is creating and this also feeds in
meditation is that man it's like this
mirror
of the collective consciousness that
people weren't ready for yeah so a
hundred years ago or even fifty years
ago you were on your small area of town
or whatever doing your thing mind your
own business and you knew the people
around you any news of the world views
and experiences and themes of what these
people thought around you and that was
sort of the scope of your own kind of
nicely insulated right right right and
just simply unaware of the complexities
and you just for the amount of people in
the rest of the world but I really
believe that the complexity is certain
degree it becomes a real frustration for
humans like whenever there's too many
things out there that one of there are
more things out there in the
experiencial world then an individual
can keep in their mind that this way at
once they get really frustrated like an
angry ape or something definite because
they're like I'm being overwhelmed by
the chaos of nature and I don't want to
submit to it yes although once you do
you'll be much happier but just look at
traffic you know it's like if you're on
a highway and there's one car you're all
good but if it's if it's gridlock and
people cutting you off you get pissed
off
yeah it's a complexity issue right and
so I think that people naively took to
the Internet and as particularly
whenever social media kicked off that
all these voices everyone has this voice
that they can spit out into the ether
and have you know cause a reflection and
so you look onto the internet and you
just see thousands and thousands and
thousands of people every day and I
think it has really done something to
the connect of subconscious of all
people because now you know if you ever
thought that you were significant we'll
just go on the internet you're gonna
feel very very small very very fast
right right exactly so that causes a lot
of tension man and that's one of the
reasons I think meditation has become
more popular is because that awareness
of all the other people creates the void
in oblivion that an individual has a
very hard time ignoring whenever it's
literally talking to them people live
Ian of the sea of humanity of the of the
entire world is there a parent in
speaking at them too
yeah you can shut it down and so it begs
the question of like one's own existence
in one's own you know the meaning within
their life I wonder if there's been an
increase in existential crises throw
yeah oh yeah overwhelming amount of
information coming in yeah I think
you're right a lot of the time
especially when I started to such type
my meditation practice and the state and
trait changes which we'll get into in a
second
for me the most noticeable thing was
just being able to create that second
moment breath between something
occurring or me having a thought and me
reacting to it yeah now rolling it a
little bit further down the line there's
that's kind of a that's definitely not
the end point but even just having that
little bit of a second extra to consider
what has happened and notice it and
interject makes such a such a profound
change day-to-day and how you deal with
situations I think you're right if if
there was a little bit more mindfulness
only a little bit more mindfulness
worldwide there would be an awful lot
less and antagonistic problems a lot
less aggression between people a lot
less misunderstanding as well because
the narratives that people are attaching
to my experience his experience their
story my story I think a lot of that
would be viewed with a much a much more
open set of eyes yeah in just the
causality of one person's shortsighted
reflexive expression of momentary
negativity or frustration is so immense
that I think it's hard for people to
really conceive of yeah because you know
one person has some dumb response to
something and they put out some you know
nasty comment or they treat someone else
negatively in the moment then it's
literally like passing the hot potato of
suffering under someone else
you know and then that person holds that
and then they're tossing up in there and
then their peers and it is gonna be on
the receiving end next exactly and it's
literally like I thought about this with
this is - but like it's the same thing
with anger or some you know negative
emotion like that is that how long has
that shockwave been going on passages
that's just moving through
yeah like did when I got a cold you know
a couple months ago and I was thinking
like like Napoleon have this cold and I
mean the anger thing that the negative
emotion thing is the same thing I'm a
big fan of not repression but of it I
think I call or I have heard called and
just end up calling I'm not sure where
but you know turning poison into
medicine or they also another term for
it is stopping the wheel of karma and
that's just like where if you get
something from somebody being able to be
high minded enough to not pass it on and
that's like snuffing out those yeah the
forest the forest fires kind of been
burned out ahead of it and it doesn't go
any further so to speak right all right
so can you give us a little bit of
background to your mindfulness practice
what you've started doing and and where
you're at now yeah sure um let's see I
started really really young I'm 36 I
started you know in my mid teenage years
essentially in the 90s there wasn't a
lot of information around around as far
as really available the internet was
sort of just sizzling as opposed to
being a raging fire as it is now and
many are just my environmental
experience and also the happenstance of
bad luck or good luck of how I saw the
world however you'd like to look at it
created an immense amount of suffering
anxiety you know an emotional suffering
within myself
and the environment that I was in was
only compounding that and I had a lot of
energy and not in the metaphysical sense
but just in a sense of vitality at the
time and I've got knowledge that's gone
away
I had a lot of energy man and I realized
that if I you know I needed to find a
way to put that in a direction or also
had the potential to be bad you know and
so since I I don't know I just had an
intuition about that and I got very much
into philosophy you know Western Eastern
philosophy at a young age kind of by
chance really
and I began after I was reading about
Neos began reading Nietzsche a lot
whenever I was my mid-teens and I
recognized that you know for the first
time I thought oh this is like this is
how I think he's on what I think per se
but it's how it's the way that my mind
you know conduits of my mind kind of
connect and then I moved over to Eastern
philosophy and I was oh this is more of
what I think and how I think in some
ways you know much more themes of
equanimity and and peacefulness and kind
of a universality and also a lack of
emphasis on the individual like I don't
think we're special and I appreciate the
the and like take that you know the
grain of salt but yeah III mean I don't
mean that like that in the nihilistic
way I mean that a sense that like we're
all just these momentary
little Wiggly fleshy you know worms of
conscious awareness that are here and
then are not here and like there's
nothing wrong with that the fact that
that's the case it's it's a beautiful
thing it's like reality is you know in
human existence is equally beautiful as
it is bleak and people clinch up with
that because they think no no life
should be seen as this like happy ending
this lawless fairy tale yeah and it's
like yeah it is man but it's also hit
like you got to acknowledge the the the
sour and the sweet and sour or else the
sauce doesn't have the twang like the
the reason for life is the twang right
yeah anyway so yeah man I appreciate the
idea of in you and Buddhism if they're
not really being a soul or anything like
that that's an it resonates well with me
in person right right and so another
thing you know as a side note in my book
I write about the upside of impermanence
because people think of impermanence and
they're always like oh what a bummer you
know everything rots and everything
this dissolves and so I doubt there that
in for their what I called the upside of
impermanence like for there to be things
to always rot there must always be
things coming into existence that's
that's the you know if you just take a
few steps back and see both sides of
that polarity then you can catch your
breath a little bit
without the accident without the yang
there is no Yin right yeah right right
so anyway man I I you just began reading
these Eastern philosophies and
what-have-you and found meditation
within those and begin practicing it
myself there was no instruction books or
anything like that
I'm gonna guess I'm gonna guess that at
this stage it was a much more as you
said before the wishy-washy sort of
difficult to follow reported experience
books of meditation as opposed to some
more of the laid out formative process
based ones that we've got today yeah
yeah there definitely wasn't a lot of
like process based things but you know
anything from Alan Watts to Robert Anton
Wilson and you know Tim Leary and some
stuff like that but then also at the
same time I was reading things like
Suzuki and like extreme hardcore Zen
like were they Zen stick stories that
they're meditating they whack you on the
back with a stick just like this is now
this is happening now there's the moment
there's the moment and the outbreak your
concentration you know so I definitely
was getting to sides but really a being
kind of auto died I by nature I went to
it just thinking okay here's some ideas
and I'm going to go experiment with
these and see what happens and so it
became your meditation became my
fortress you know I realized that during
that period of of suffering and being
feeling like I was not interlocking with
the world in my environment and
surroundings the inner world my inner
life became very rich because I was able
to meditate and feel you know and really
consciously intellectually separate my
experience with okay no matter what's
happening outside of my body outside of
my skin internally none of that stuff
can affect me here and none of the you
know whatever you'd like to call it this
is the the pain and suffering that was
feeling in that time like none of that
has a place within my my mind yet my
mind became my sanctuary
have you read the month search for
meaning by Viktor Frankl I have yeah
yeah so mungs
final Bastian is his ability to choose
his response in any given situation
right right it's the thought that your
ability to respond and your thoughts
within your mind are yours and they'll
always be yours mm-hmm except for I love
that idea
but I also can't believe into
determinism so you know you know it's
it's it's kind of it's interesting isn't
it to hold both of those things at the
same time yeah yeah it's like I think
that my you know ability to choose my
choices is really beautiful yep that's a
very very good way to put it so right
man so I was doing the you know into
meditation like that it eventually just
became this very fundamental aspect of
my my existence and carried on so even
where ever my life began to balance
probably much because of meditation in a
lot of ways it just continued on with
the practice and I just continued
exploring I'm very inquisitive little
critter and I I'm always spent a lot of
time especially my early twenties like
trying to find the edges of reality in
my own perception and like what my
consciousness was and I did a lot of
experimentation and in a lot of
different realms trying to understand
that and what's interesting from my
point of view now was in that time you
know stretching my late teens and you
know doing a lot of psychedelics and
meditation just going as far deep as I
could with these things and you know
thought experiments is that I went
through all of that and then really calm
down with that because I found the edges
I played in the middle of the street I
was able to
what was going in on in the yard across
the street yeah and I was able to sit
back and then begin to reflect on what I
had experienced man so I had ten years
of reflecting on my experience and
continuing to unpack and contemplate
those things and then within the last
five years the the new wave of interest
in psychedelics and consciousness and
all this stuff really kicked up so it
was a really curious unfolding in
society for me because I was like
watching all of these people who were
just getting into this way of thinking
that I had kind of no know was so long
right yeah I had no know and I felt
comfortable with my comprehension of it
for so long and had time to reflect on
so it's very interesting so it was good
timing it was good timing a lot of
people getting into that set of
interests and being able to arrive with
a reflected point of view whenever it
was needed do you feel the do you feel
fortunate to be in a position where you
can assist people at the you know riding
the crest of this wave so to speak as
there's a big uptake in in mindfulness
practice and a big interest in it well
then I mean I don't really like put
myself in my own image of the greater
picture yeah a lot of times I look at it
all as if you and I were sitting in a
bar or something talking and you said
you're interested in meditation and I
was like oh cool man and we could talk
about it for a little while and I tell
you whatever I thought essentially I
would be telling you my experiences not
answers but just ideas and thoughts and
things I experienced so what I thought
about them and how they were helpful to
me yeah and it you know if you find any
of that helpful then that's fantastic
and you can take that with you and add
that to your map I look at doing it on a
large scale the exact same way you know
I don't look at like oh I am able to and
I totally take your point and I
appreciate what you're saying but just
as far as the way that I interact with
it all it's not a cell frond it's not
steaming in as Corey Alan meditation
master third third third degree black
black belt right I think I think again
that speaks to the practice right that
speaks to the detachment from the ego
and so on and so yes yeah so that was
probably a bit of a trick question
actually you could trick yourself
because it sound like you just realized
tricked everyone yeah so I want to try
and start from the absolute basics the
most important principles that you think
that you can explain to someone for when
undertaking a mindfulness practice can
you start at the bottom in the end and
and take it from there yeah sure man so
you you touched on something that's very
valuable up at the the front of our
conversation which was you know not
everything in life has to be this
pursuit where you you become a master
you think about how many things in like
how many things are you a master at in
life probably say maybe zero yeah yeah
exactly
there might be you know a couple of
things that you're really good at most
people have things that they're
naturally really good at but they're
this is another part of the confusion of
meditation is that people think I've got
to do this and become a master of it and
it's like no that's not really the point
the point is to doing as much of the
practice that you need to feel a balance
and a change that works for you and so
I'd stress for people like you don't
need to be meditating on the side of a
mountain for ten hours a day for the
rest of your life what you need to do is
just enough to create that extra little
space that mindfulness gap to where you
can recognize your own flow of
consciousness your own flow of thoughts
enough to not get into a chain of
reactive behavior and just be able to
respond to your own life as opposed to
being carried away in your reactive
programmed you observe no attached right
you right watch it happen rather than a
touching
soft ooh it yeah in the dances of course
when you do it enough to where that all
becomes synchronous yes and so the you
know the the best thing man for someone
who's just starting is don't make it a
big deal that's super important is don't
make it a big deal because it's not a
big deal you meditate every night while
you're sleeping the only difference is
you're just gonna try and do it while
you're awake a little bit right so you
just sit in the chair maybe on your
couch will lay down whatever is the most
comfortable for you and just close your
eyes and put your phone or stuff away
and just relax your body and take ten
deep breaths nothing unnatural just
allow your chest to expand and again and
exhale and when you're doing that you
know with your eyes closed just kind of
point your attention to your chest no
big deal just rising and falling and
just you just try ten breaths and then
perhaps you'll try and count them so if
you count one breath end and one exhale
and two breaths in and two exhales and
just try and get to ten and see if you
can count ten breaths and most people
can most people can't distract it at
three right what's the breakfast I
wonder I wonder if the cat's being let
out yet all right is that for breakfast
yeah there's nothing you know thoughts
get weird but there's nothing wrong with
that at all and if if one becomes
distracted whenever you realize that you
just acted just started one again with
this breath counting and if you can sit
there and do that for five minutes in
the morning or any evening before you go
to bed you'll notice the difference in
your daily life if you can do that for
10 minutes you'll notice a bigger
difference and so on and so on and I
think that it's important for one not to
try and sit and meditate for half an
hour for the first time yeah because the
ants eNOS is gonna be you know pretty
unbearable if you think about your hands
on a biological level you
you're so used to just messing with
things constantly always with your phone
on a keyboard with your TV remote you're
making food you're just always doing
something that to not do something you
almost feel like phantom limb syndrome
yeah like ah my hands right so I think
that you know after five minutes or so
you try it a couple of times you get
over the fidgets and an interesting
thing happens begins Adam is that
whenever you're you know the the mind is
reflected in the body and vice versa and
so the chatter of the brain begins to
calm down the chatter of the body begins
to calm down and wherever you can get to
where you can just rest your hands on
yourself
while you're breathing or just wherever
you'd like to rest them then you'll
notice that like there's this connection
between the clarity of mind and your
ability to let go and just release your
body and relax it yeah and it should not
be a feeling of like where your your
shrink-wrapped in you're claustrophobic
within your own skin it's not babies
right yeah just literally like letting
go and allowing your body to just be
there yeah I think it's been a really a
really good analogy what you said about
not trying to steam in at half an hour
to begin with the analogy for those
people who go to the gym you wouldn't
walk into the gym and try and pick up
try and deadlift 250 kilos you start off
and it's progressive overload right
right right
where can I go today can can it go six
can it go seven can it go ten can we go
so yeah so you're Zak
yes you're sitting you're hopefully now
starting to develop a practice where the
movement in the body and the anxiousness
and the agitation in the body has
started to come and then why are we
going from that so from there then
you'll you'll want to try and make that
consecutive so you want to make sure you
can try that a couple of times here and
there when it appeals to you or most
people reach for that practice whenever
they're feeling extreme amounts of
stress and looking for some type of
solution to it or anxiety or whatever it
might be I will tell you is that people
will often look for optimizing solutions
one of their
negative circumstances you know if
you're feeling sick people try no I
better eat right and you know not you
know hit the bar or something like that
because I don't want to get myself even
more ill or if I'm really stressed on a
meditate but this is the net gain aspect
of meditation is very very valuable if
you're going in for a job interview or
an important conversation or you know a
first date or something like that
meditating beforehand is very valuable
because you're if you're feeling fine
and you meditate anyway you'll be that
much more calm and focused and present
for your action this should minuting
shouldn't be hitting the antidote button
it's the the multivitamin button right
exactly exactly and so the beautiful
thing in the real real deep result it
one will find from meditation is doing
it consecutively so after you you
perhaps someone tries meditating here
and there whenever they need it and they
realize oh this is kind of helping me
this is I noticed a little shift in my
brain maybe if you feel a little a
little high or something afterwards and
I I used to back you know was looping
back around to my teenagers I used to
read until I felt high like that was
like that was how I knew I could stop is
what I read like it run is that like a
run as high but yeah it's always knew
that my brain was stretching it's like
if I read like enough of this idea of
this concept until I feel stoned I know
that synapses are popping yeah yeah so
but you will feel a bit of or often a
person will feel a bit of difference in
their consciousness after meditation and
that's really a awareness of your own
awareness you're talking immediately
after a practice or around to practice
that right yeah yeah you'll find this
right after a practice or even during
you can feel this like oh I feel a bit
different you know and it's it's this
awareness of your awareness you're a
more present and so there's more
information that your nervous system is
taking in because it's more aware and
there's more detail and nuance in your
experience of life
and that becomes a a orientation a
permanent orientation once you practice
meditation consecutively just as the
analogy used was stretching
if you stretch you know I like to run a
lot and if you were to to never stretch
that would be bad obviously you hurt so
but if you stretch once a week and
you're running 20 miles a week you're
going to not feel well but if you
stretch every day it becomes easier and
easier to stretch each time it becomes
vital and crucial this is the same thing
with meditation you know if you meditate
once it is helpful for the moment but
you're going to find yourself back in
the place that you were and then if you
do it every day you're just going to
feel this inherent flexibility that
becomes a part of your daily experience
yeah I think one of the things that you
touched on was a point I really wanted
to try and get across to people which is
state versus trait changes mmm in your
experience so state changes would be
those which you experience during and
immediately around doing some meditation
practice whether it be 5 or 20 minutes
or half an hour and trait changes are
the ones which you would notice
throughout your day-to-day experience
away from the practice a significant
period of time away from the practice I
think a lot of the time people expect
and they look for the trait changes
first which I've meditated for five days
in a row but I still got angry because
my husband was late for dinner or
whatever it might be
whereas the the state changes for me
occurred very quickly I felt very very
calm quite quickly after spending ten to
fifteen minutes calming the mind hmm is
there is is there a
is there a level of time or amount of
time and attention that where people
will begin to noticed rate changes yes I
would say you know typically the the
word on that is around two weeks it's
what if you really begin to feel those
those deeper changes and that could have
something to do with neuroplasticity
shifts and kind of retraining the actual
framework of the brain in the mind and
what-have-you and it does seem to be
around that time the people notice that
how I would like to make just a
clarification in that you know we're
still like everyone's still human right
and so to begin a meditation practice
with the thinking that like all right
here's what's cool is I'm never gonna
feel angry again it's like this is gonna
be cool I'm gonna do this and I'm gonna
be a Zen master gonna be completely
immune to all emotions both negative and
positive I'm just turning a like Brandon
Stark in Game of Thrones at the moment
just let this turnip in the corner of
the room by the way that's one of my
favorite you know UK sayings is turnip
is cool
I'm glad you said it I like tennis a lot
and wherever I hear Andy Murray yell
call himself a turnip it always makes me
laugh that's such a Scottish thing to
call yourself as well fun because
there's lots of people in the crowd
calling you other things and it's yeah
it's not a turnip but yeah like that
Brandon Stark thing for anyone who's
watching Game of Thrones at the moment
it makes me laugh because that that kind
of complete detachment from everything
that's going on is kind of like the 30
seconds if someone was to walk in after
I've done a half an hour meditation
practice within 30 seconds of me
finishing that's how I feel like I would
respond like just completely like I
don't know just detached and out of it
and slowly trying to bring myself back
to reality but it was it was so funny
when he when when that started
come up in the in the Game of Thrones
thing a couple of my friends who do yoga
meditation as well mentioned the same
thing they said do you think that
Brandon's actually got any green site or
whatever it's called or has he just been
absolutely be pounding the meditation
for the last well he's been in the
wheelchair now see this is funny to me
because I actually don't find I suppose
I did for a while but I don't find to
feel more removed and internal after my
meditations I actually feel more
interwove on with the external world
afterwards that's interesting I
definitely say as someone who's done a
consistent practice for about two to two
and a half years now maybe yeah maybe
two years I wouldn't say that that's my
that that marries with my experience not
yet when I brought a little more flexing
back here I'm thinking you know I think
I've been meditating about twenty years
yeah and reflecting back I think that
there was a long period of time where I
would feel yeah I've always been a big
coffee drinker so my routine for four
years was like meditating and then
drinking a giant you're pounding a giant
coffee that's like that's like taking
the taking the dip down before getting
on the roller coaster right to the top
right right it's like a slingshot yeah
but no I'm now thinking back yeah I do
I do think I recall there being a long
stretch like that and eventually I think
my interest after my you know a decade
or whatever were 15 years my body seemed
to finally calm down and I was able to
just accept my own existence a bit more
and you know that's that's a tricky one
yep but I think that these days not too
fast for it too much but these days my
meditation is very much
um just watching and in my meditation
and I described disking recently is that
I think that a observing the outer world
and the inner world while also
simultaneously observing that from our
bird's eye view above all three at the
same time yeah that to me is what my
meditation is like it's an it's an
interlocking of looking at what's out
there looking what's inside and then
watching those two things meet well I
watch I think there's definitely a lot
to be said for early on in your practice
there's a lot of unexplored territory
internally
and I can imagine I can imagine that
that maybe some of the carryover
immediately after your practice that
wherever just being what was I just
thinking about how can my mind so quiet
you know as you as you slowly come round
to back back into the physical realm so
to speak no I think that's a wonderful
distinction man yeah absolutely
so what would you say in terms of once
once people have begun to build up a
practice of the consistency so optimal
frequency daily yeah you know daily and
I would say I probably meditate five
days a week and it's just really
important to not make it a chore you
know because people will find a way to
resent it
and find a way to be able to pass it up
if it becomes a thing they they feel
like they have to do yes
so just don't like being told what to do
even by themselves would not our own
slaves right yet one of my what if one
of the guys who's on the podcast all the
time Youssef says meditation isn't
something we have to do it's something
we get to do absolutely absolutely but I
think eventually it becomes to me anyway
it becomes like brushing your teeth you
know it's like you don't even think
about I hope not you know you don't even
think about you just do it as a part of
your your daily experience and it's not
a I don't know many people that are like
oh god I got to go brush my teeth again
you know it's like it's like it's a good
thing you know it helps helps you stay
fresh and and crispy clean and the
meditation is no different so we've got
optimal frequency at between daily to
five times a week yeah
what about optimal session length once
you've worked up your tolerance yeah man
I think that once you've become more
accustomed to meditating something
longer than five or 10 minutes I would
say
a twenty to thirty is really a great
target zone because that way you're not
hacking away an hour of your day or 45
minutes of your day you're not becoming
bored to the experience it's enough to
really have a deep effect yet not make
one psychologically feel like they're
devoting too much time to it
and I know is that mace even sound a
little weird but just the nature of
human time management and psychology and
all that stuff I think it's sort of an
important thing to keep in mind and your
Tamia I generally there's something
magical about the 20-minute zone
20-minute mark to me and I've spoke with
other people who are deep meditators and
they've reciprocated that idea so I
think the 20 to 30 minute timeline is
nice because our time zone rather
because you can get to that spot where
you're just like a tree blowing in the
breeze without a name or identity and
then you know then we have embraced that
watching period for a while and
experience just consciousness yes
awareness man I think can I think
there's certainly but I bought my mum
listeners will know what I'm gonna say I
bought my mum headspace at the start of
the year because I wanted she's a Reiki
Master of 10 years and has done a lot in
the esoteric side big in Pilates big in
yoga but never actually doing any formal
mindfulness practice I thought right
okay
headspace and she likes doing five and
10-minute meditations and I had sat down
and had a chat with her and said one of
the things that I brought up was that in
a five or a 10 minute meditation for me
personally the first 50% or more the
first five minutes - 10 minutes is just
quieting the mind mm-hmm when you're
doing there's a kind like an overhead
that needs to be paid there's a price
there's an entry fee that you need to
pay to get to the state I suppose that
over time would you say that you are
able to drop into deepest deeper states
of meditation more quickly kind of like
dropping into REM sleep more quickly I
suppose yeah I mean in my experience yes
yes and I think that it's a the analogy
of drawing is a good one it's
essentially like warming up you know
you're like if you had all this stuff
going on and God knows what's happening
in your day and in your life and in your
mind at that time or even just where the
you're in neurobiology of your brain is
that at them
I mean this some days where I feel more
fragmented in there some days where I
feel quite sharp and so you know it just
whatever the day calls for it's kind of
what in my opinion the meditation calls
for just look at it like a meal you know
if you're really hungry you're gonna
probably want to eat a little bit more
if you're not that hungry then the snack
will do and I think that meditation you
know as far as that time of getting into
the actual target zone is the same to me
like I think I spend two or three
minutes just kind of getting comfortable
like getting physically getting just how
I want to be yeah and that should be for
any I suppose for any people person
might be listening that is interested
that would be if you were in a sitting
meditation position I would suggest that
you look at your legs and hips as a
foundation think of it as like the
foundation of a building and then the
spine growing up and expressing outwards
almost like a like a tree or a flower
something growing upwards then the body
hangs you know the shoulders are back
chest is forward your firm but but not
tight it's it's like being proud but not
being arrogant you know that's that's
yeah and then then the head just floats
on top like you literally just your
head's like a cherry on top of the
sundae that's it's a good way to have a
foundation because you'll want to be
tight but you won't be firm that's well
that's one that's all my lines yeah well
I'm hearing I'm hearing snippets from
releasing a now just coming back at me
just done on live here instead of
instead of hearing them that's cool on a
recording yeah that's cool so you
touched on this earlier and it's
something that I really want to bring up
with you so you've mentioned that
starting your meditation practice with a
psychedelic experience in advance can
change the nature of your practice by I
may be putting words in your mouth but
by giving you something to aim for
or I don't know if I've taken that out
of context but that meditation practice
after having psychedelic experiences can
take on a different kind of a different
kind of role and can be viewed in a
different way would you be able to
elaborate on that yeah I mean at the end
of the day whether it be meditation or a
psychedelic experience these are really
just ways to manipulate one's own
consciousness and I think that if you
were to take a psychedelic what often
will happen is a person becomes more
aware of their own mind not necessarily
in a good way but they become aware of
their own consciousness aware of their
awareness and their experience more and
their perception begins to become a bit
more modular and that the locked-in
programmed ways that they saw the world
and their subjective perception of it
begins to shift and become malleable and
such that they begin perceiving things
differently and to simplify and to make
that more easy to understand to someone
who has not had that experience if you
were to look at the classic picture of
is that a vase or is that two faces
facing each other and you look at the
two faces and oh it's two faces and then
you focus on the vase anything oh no
it's a vase well truly of course it's
both at the same time but it really is
an accord to how you're perceiving it to
that moment well under a psychedelic
experience you know the world becomes
that way in in a lot of ways and so that
truly is just the nature of your
perception becomes more clear to you or
it can as a potential to meditation is
the same thing it's just a different
pathway in a different you know method
of getting to that place and I would say
a much more stable and agreeable and
lock beneficial one I think so that's a
good very good analogy and a good thing
to mention as well that the the stable
secure route to the top of the mountain
rather than strapping yourself into a
cannon and getting fired directly to the
top and so you getting to the top of the
mountain with no context or knowledge or
wisdom is kind of a wasted ticket to the
top of the mountain and Allah
of cases in most cases because you know
you really just need experience and time
and time to understand what you're even
thinking and understand what you're
experiencing and reflecting on those
experiences before you can have you know
a lot of benefit from those places you
know I personally I did it the other way
I did against the way I'm talking about
is it really just like smearing my brain
across the you know top of the cosmos
and then trying to pick up the pieces
together directive yes
chasing chasing the fragments of my
consciousness around the galaxy and then
hoping that I haven't missed the way
always have extra pieces when you put
something together yeah yeah and so but
but you know in that this is why earlier
I was mentioning how I had a long time
to reflect on those experiences and
things dawned on me you know ten years
later say oh that's what I was
experiencing at that moment now I had
the time to understand it and you know I
think that meditation is really valuable
in the sense that we'll just answer your
previous question like yes if you have a
psychedelic experience and then go to
meditate it can frame and give you
context for what you already experienced
and then also you will be a bit familiar
with the simple state of consciousness
change regardless of the method if once
you go to met that you can recognize you
know as they say game recognizes the
game you can recognize the game a little
bit like oh okay I know this feeling I
know that this is consciousness shifting
so but I will say man is that I I have
gotten to where I'm so I'm just not
really interested in it's actually even
curious to me like I'm not even
interested in consciousness state
changes many in many regards these days
like you know I'm not really interested
in psychedelics or it hardly even
alcohol even though I do drink my wine
several other several nights a week
can stuff like that but I don't really
even want to I just got do because it's
sort of like a nice social fun thing to
do and it's tasty but I'm not looking
for state changes yeah I don't crave or
desire state why do you think that is I
think it's because I am so into my
natural flow of thinking and I enjoy my
natural resting state of my
consciousness more than an altered state
it's richer and more full to me than an
altered state is now like one could you
smoke smoke weed and like they would get
stoned and they would get giggly because
things change and shift and become
different and whatever to them and then
they come back down to the regular state
or one could take a psychedelic and have
these far-out thoughts and all this
stuff and then come back I think to me
like my resting state of awareness is
more interesting to me than one of those
those other skewed states feel like a
downer or like they're just boring or
confusing or like sort of just murky but
my resting awareness is just really
pleasurable like I just like it it's
like it's so much it's really fun yeah
and deep and rich and there's never an
end to you know the things to be thought
about or the experiences to be enjoyed
and taken in and I you know there's
could be a lot of reasons for that but
it is what it is I think it's a good
thing that I just enjoy the Sun by in my
own experience and I will say is that
especially five about four or five years
ago I was then surrounded by a lot of
people who were almost marketing
consciousness change a lot to others and
I never agreed with that and and because
at the same time I was going through
this that shift I was just describing
yeah and what I realized when I really
put away
pretty much everything and I'm not
saying that I'm like straight edge dude
type of now but I find that a bite is
much more satisfying than a meal yeah to
me with these type of things and I found
that one of the reasons my interest me
so much and I really began to seek that
path was because I realized what I was
just talking about as far as getting
into a consciousness shifting type of
space and then coming down to normal and
this could be you know what name pick
your poison yeah but everybody's always
coming back down was just like well what
is the point what is what do you I just
don't I didn't see the utility in that
because what I'm interested is long-term
permanent shifting change one step
forward one step back right right you
know 20 20 steps forward 20 steps back
yeah well even or even more because if
you go into an illusory state with no
context or or no mind to observe and
absorb the potential learning in that
state that it actually adds to one's
delusion yes and it so it gives you even
more steps back hundred there's the
romanticized idea of evolution of your
consciousness in that state so people
think that they are evolving however
they're actually devolving and becoming
really religious they're coming to image
to the narrative aren't they if this is
my experience this is where I am going
I'd said something a little bit less a
little bit less mindful but similarly
appropriate I think what I was
discussing with Dominic McGregor who is
a recovering alcoholic CEO of the UK's
largest social media agency and we were
talking about the common culture amongst
young people that going out every
weekend and getting smashed drunk on
alcohol and partying and leaving on a
Friday and getting home on a Sunday
night is is very very common and one of
the things that I said was how
overwhelming the experiences of having a
lot of alcohol and then when you add in
stronger drugs MDMA party drugs and
pills and stuff
what blows my mind is that people travel
to the other side of the planet they'll
go on a a stag do or a birthday party or
whatever they'll travel to Thailand or
Vegas or Marbella or in Europe or
wherever it might be and they will put
themselves into a chemically induced
state that is so overwhelming that they
have no discernable difference in their
experience from them going to their
local pub and Rahim bhai taking the
exact same substances and I said that
when you go away and you do this
yourself all that you're doing is
electing to have a hangover or a calm
down in a slightly different location
and then once the hangover come downs
gone away you get back on it you get
transported right back to the same place
which might as well be anywhere in the
world but you're in Vegas or you're in
Marbella or you're in wherever and you
wake up the next day and you suffer the
hangover in a different in a different
location totally I think you just came
up with a really good business idea
because I have really like faux
international exotic destinations like
in your local area that you can go there
and you know it's like a bar out of your
mind yeah but it feels like Thailand or
something yeah it's pretty close mice
might as well be yeah exactly so eating
a lot less time to get that but I
totally agree man and to me wherever I
see someone who's smashed or whatever it
just looks like suffering to me it looks
makes me sad I see someone that's you
know passed out and spilled their drink
all themselves or whatever and I just
think it's it's really important I mean
man I was I was a soldier and with
alcohol for how long long well served
that time right yeah yeah for a very
long never missed a day of work
you know yeah strict conscription yeah
but it just yeah man just it looks like
suffering to me anyone in its
that's I I think that it's it's just
unfortunate but what it is man my job
I've done for eleven years now I run
club nights that's my job I'm a club
promoter we run a number of events in
Newcastle Manchester in the UK and Dom
asked me a really interesting question
on the podcast and he said can you see
the people that are suffering when
they're on a night out and I said no I
can't usually it's the people who are
the most outgoing and the ones that are
appearing to have the best time who
often are the ones that really probably
shouldn't be there and really probably
should put that next drink down but yeah
you're right the the suffering thing
it's it's really difficult at the moment
if I'm honest for me to hold in hold in
the same world that I'm trying to
encourage mindfulness practice I'm
currently doing six months sober
because I wanted to challenge myself
last year and see if I could and I
really enjoyed what happened when I did
and I'm doing it again this year and I'm
encouraging other people to do it but
that my livelihood
is still built around a business across
multiple cities in the UK right requires
people to get drunk and we mark it ruins
prices and I write the social media and
I I push the narrative and I think for
some people it's absolutely fine and the
listeners will know what I'm going to
say that for some people going out and
party in every weekend and going hard is
absolutely fine
but for some people it's not for some
people when they wake up the next day
the thoughts that come into their head
are more than just oh god I feel a
little bit sick it becomes self
referential it becomes anxiety inducing
it becomes labeling and after a little
while it becomes so much a part of you
the hangover becomes so much a part of
you that it's difficult to actually
separate yourself from it even when
you're fine and I think that I think
that mindfulness practice again helps to
break down some of the some of the
little white lies and some of the fibs
that you've told yourself about why
you're doing
certain things and I think you start to
you start to assess and ask questions of
yourself about what you're spending your
time doing and about why you're doing it
that you wouldn't have done usually I
think that that can sometimes bring up
some quite ugly answers actually one of
the one of the guys who I mentioned
mindfulness to her about a year ago said
something to the effect of I really
don't want to quite in my mind because I
don't know I I don't think I'd like what
I'd hear and I think that that's um
that's an interesting an interesting
idea to think about it
it is man I would tell that person well
join the club you know yeah join the
club man we all have negative thoughts
but I think the the lesson or the thing
to understand there is that like you
weren't your thoughts your what thoughts
you put into action you are not even
your emotions emotions are things that
pass through you and so there's nothing
wrong with having you know that negative
thoughts were crazy insane thoughts I
have them all time it's just a matter of
if you recognize them and let them go or
if you put them at the action because
you are what you act out not what you
think
right so meditation would you say it's
not about stopping the thoughts it's
about a detachment from them will not
even detachment which is like
acknowledgement and then being able to
actually you know I heard Thomas
medicine injure the German philosopher
said it well where's like thoughts are
like a bunch of little kids in a line
they're always gonna be there in your
mind but so always kind of walk up to
you and want your attention and you just
need to give them attention for a minute
and then we'll move on and they give the
next one attention and it'll move on and
every once in a while those kids will
sort of be doing their own thing and
there'll be a gap in that line and
that's where you can you'll have a
moment of fire or have a little bit of
peace yeah but you know regardless of if
that thing that's coming to your
attention is good or bad not getting
wrapped up in it is key
and recognizing that you have the
ability to to control that and that
you're also can allow yourself to let go
of any potential guilt or feelings of
negativity because I hear people say I'm
an awful person I just thought this it's
like no you're just a person you know we
all think horrible things you know I put
there's a chapter or a section of my
book I put judgment is in our DNA that's
like the title it's this whole thing on
like a kind of evolutionary psychology
approach to why I think that we all have
judgment and it's just recognizing that
that's a part of the expression of the
human mind and then like not taking it
personally just knowing what to do with
it
yeah it's like it's like saying like oh
I saw hard to be gross but that's like
saying like oh I take a [ __ ] every day
and that makes me disgusting because
shit's disgusting yeah so it's just a
part of being the biological expression
of being human you just know what to do
with it if you'd left it in the living
room then yeah that'd be close you put
it where it goes yeah and then move on
and then it's fine fine yeah so Eve
touch on a couple of times about the
book am i right in saying that first
first draft gone off yes yes Lou what
can you tell us so far
yeah so that's right now it's called now
is the way and it's basically turned
into an argument against the acceptance
of a given amount of human suffering you
know there are these the way in which we
perceive an approach our world
I think inherently has a lot of kinks
and a lot of assumed qualities to it and
to re-examine your own perspective from
a different point of view can really
alleviate and relieve a lot of the
pressure and suffering that we feel as
as humans and so it deals with a lot of
evolutionary psychology here and there
but also a lot of you know seams of
consciousness or touch on and and even
accepting oneself
you know accepting other people goes
kind of deep into the self and identity
and how to allow yourself to evolve and
become the person that you'd like to be
and a couple of chapters on meditation
you know so yeah it's it's also very
also encapsulated humor into it too it's
it's not dry you know there's definitely
some moments of is definitely left to
think about but it's also light and kind
of silly in a lot of places as well so
I'm very excited about it and you know
early 2019 ISM it should be available
that's awesome did you enjoy writing the
book oh yeah I had a fantastic time it
was great did he find it challenging to
try and pull together so many failed you
mentioned so I've evolutionary biology
anthropology stuff like that did you was
the room was most of this stuff kind of
floating around and you obviously you
mentioned that you do a lot of reading
and that you've got this
so if moderately insatiable desire for
information did you have to delve much
deeper or did you have it sort of a good
framework already existing before you
started I had a good framework and I
think that any you know creative project
takes on a life of its own once you get
in the flow with it and so I had a
general outline and I don't I don't
think if person has everything planned
out to a tee then they go create the
thing in and nothing changes I think
that might be wise to reassess what
you've done
yeah because the thing needs to wake up
and like if a piece of yourself doesn't
come out of nowhere
you know out of the ether and arrive and
come to life in the moment then there's
something missing right but I had a
general idea and scaffolding and then
that evolved and and took its own form
as I continued to actually flush it out
and write it
that's fascinating I've got Johann Hari
the author of lost connections
I've got him coming on very soon and he
he mentioned in his in his book about
some of the evolutionary basis for human
suffering one of them being loneliness
and the
the justification and the understanding
for that for me was so eye-opening it
was like um it was like having my
worldview sort of smashed apart
consistantly chapter after chapter he'd
have you read have you read the book if
you read lost you know I'm not familiar
with him at all
Johan is he's a British guy he's the
book lost connection sees focuses on
depression and anxiety the the real
causes of depression and their
surprising solutions and in one of them
he discusses about why loneliness exists
what's the reason for loneliness and he
said that 100,000 years ago let's say
human evolution were nomadic tribes were
living living on planes and we weren't
stronger than animals we weren't faster
we could run them down over long
distances but the real strategy the real
skill the humans have was their ability
to coordinate their teamwork and that
the tribe was your protection it wasn't
a horn on the top of your head it wasn't
you
claws it was the tribe to tribe as your
your power and that if you as a human
being were left on your own away from
the tribe your body needed to signal to
you get the [ __ ] back there as fast as
possible and it would try and issue all
of these physiological responses that
make you yearn for contact because a
human on his own is a human that's dead
and he talks about some studies which
have been done on tribes that still live
in a similar a similar fashion to how we
would have done and he says that there
is a there's a metric that you can use
for measuring loneliness and during your
sleep you'll have these micro awakenings
and you won't remember them when you
wake up in the morning but everybody has
them and they worked out that the model
loneliness that someone feels the more
of these micro awakenings will occur
and the reason for that is that if
you're on your own sleeping in a cave
without the protection of the tribe
around you your body does not want to
let you go absolutely to sleep it wants
you to be just on the cusp of waking up
at all times as a protectionist strategy
right Simeon's so that you're not too
deep so that you're not too far away
from from the animals coming and waking
you up and you can hear them coming from
further off and they've done this study
on this tribe and the micro waiting's
were almost non-existent throughout all
of them because this sense of belonging
and this sense of group identity that
that was safe was so high that they
didn't need they didn't need these and I
thought that was a really interesting
eye opening um explanation of why
something that is so ubiquitous so
common for everyone to feel everyone
knows what loneliness feels like right
but mm-hmm
it has its roots in our development and
for me too you know you've mentioned the
evolution human biology element that
you'll be discussing that for me is such
a it's such a liberating fact to find
out should I mean that this isn't my
sole experience this suffering hasn't
just been bestowed on me there's
hundreds of thousands of years of people
who've suffered it before me and there
will be to come yeah I think I think
that's a really really grounding way to
think about things I agree man and I
feel that in the book anyway I call that
the evolutionary hangover is this like
where technology evolves so fast and
humans evolve so slowly that were fresh
out of the jungle and we're still trying
to deal with these you know hundred
thousand two and a thousand year old
imperatives biological imperatives while
at the same time we have iPhones and the
internet and all this type of thing
cracking along and so there's a tension
between the lower brain and the upper
brain and we're still working that out I
think it's kind of being addressed right
now it's beginning to be addressed and
so I just that
throughout the entire book one of the
things I mentioned is that like is just
as a joke sort of but it is a strange
fact is that you know there are still
Amazonian hunter or there I'm sorry
there are still hunter and gatherer
tribes in the Amazon
however amazon.com will deliver your
groceries to you in two hours mmm yeah
having again having those two things
exist in the same world seems seems very
strange doesn't it yeah yeah indeed so I
wanted to ask you one final question
have you talked have you got any idea of
the total amount of practice time that
you've undergone sure I can you be able
to work out how much time you've spent
meditating oh man let me just take let
me take a wild guess when we bus have to
calculator real quick and you think
about it let's see and I'll be real no
one certainly no one's gonna fact no
one's gonna fact-check you well I'd like
to know you know I'd like to know a real
answer here yeah let's see I'd be very
conservative
let's see Tim's 20 / I mean I'll just
conservative let's say at least
thousands of in thousands of hours which
is limited we'll leave it there that is
I've got really interesting I'll send
you the link and I'll make sure the link
is in the description there's a really
interesting observed change flowchart of
what happens at 10 hours of hundred
hours five hundred a thousand five
thousand ten thousand hours of
meditation anecdotal anecdotal stories
about what someone's experiences like
and also the observed changes in the
brain and I think if your experience of
life is anything like what the 1000
hours says the one to five thousand
hours says I think you're living a
little bit of a different experience
than I am but so to round off where can
the listeners find you
line they can just go to koi - Alan calm
there is links to my podcast the extra
hustle there are articles I've written
on various topics and some of my music
some of my binaural beats for meditation
all sorts of things are available there
fantastic thank you so much for you time
Corey I really appreciate it
hopefully we've managed to make
meditation a little bit less daunting
for some of the listeners I've had a lot
of messages already from people saying
that they're keen to try and if this is
the push that gets them through the door
then I think that we've spent a night
it's been an hour very well spent yeah I
appreciate it man thank you Chris and
like I said earlier right there should
be no there's nothing to fear there is
no thing to fear about meditation it's
as I said you're doing it every night
you're doing it all the time you just
have to realize you're doing it and then
pointed in the right direction
I heard I mean absolutely Corey thank
you very much for your time thank you
cheers mate
[Music]